[Music]
heather morris is honoring nia rivera in
a special way
on monday the glee star shared a video
of herself dancing tanaya's rare song
radio silence on instagram
[Music]
the actress opened up to fans about how
she's struggling to cope with the death
of her co-star
who died earlier this month after a boat
ride with her son at lake piru
in ventura county california heather
wrote
grieving looks very differently on
everyone but one thing's for certain
i felt it's hard to feel joy or keep
busy one morning without thinking that
you're not honoring that person
or you're forgetting about them the
dancing with the stars alum revealed her
husband reminded her that
honoring someone can mean you're
enjoying your life for them
[Music]
heather also said she gained 1 million
followers
in the past weeks at first she said she
felt resentful since it came from a
tragedy
but now acknowledges a deeper meaning
quote
i realized you all have just surrounded
me with love and support
that i just see you angels wrapping your
wings around me
to celebrate the milestone heather
emotionally danced tanaya's voice
[Music]
radio silence was just one of the songs
from nya's unreleased album
back in 2013 et talked to the singer on
what fans would have expected from it
i'm singing things like i've written and
they're like you know they're each my
little baby
this is like my love child it's taken
two and a half years
really yeah two and a half years i've
been signed to sony columbia
and in that time i've been trying out
different producers and different songs
and still writing and
i wasn't cracking the code and i was
like i'm i'm anxious to put something
out but i'm not going to put it out if
it's not right if it's not really me and
i don't believe in it
heather and nya played girlfriends
turned wives on glee
i love you so much and the pair formed a
super close bond on
and off screen who are you still closest
with from the glee yeah well um you know
and i
and i keep in touch a lot yeah and you
are you guys kind of bonding over the
mom thing now you have that in common
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like we've
taken our kids to
you know the railroad park and just we
like to keep in touch and just like
you know talk about things going on in
our life
you